you
hi everyone is cheering if you play the
Royal of PES or find yourself on the
defending side of it the Noah's Ark trap
is something free to be aware of it
starts off after the moves efore e5
Knight f3 knight c6 but should be v eh6
and Bishop a4 with now d6 we're entering
the modern Steinitz variation of this
opening now a logical enough move for
white is d4 striking in the center
looking to maybe grab on E
or even exploit the pin on the knight
with the d5 but black has a good
response
it's b5 breaking the pin on the knight
and after the bishop is kicked back and
now a group of three exchanges on d4
starting first with Knight takes on d4
Knight takes Knight takes Knight and if
white is impatient and immediately
recaptures on d4 they found for the
Noah's Ark trap now a better
continuation at this point would be
something like Bishop d5 the rook side
steps the threat we enter a roughly
equal position but just to highlight
what will happen if the Queen
immediately recaptures on d4 we now have
a flurry of attacks and counter-attacks
and after all is said and done it's
black who gets the last laugh here's how
it works
it's c5 first striking it the Queen
preparing c4 to trap the bishop and that
this can only be prevented for so long
after Queen d5 and appealing enough move
a dual threat hitting at f7 for me as
well as the rook in the corner there's a
convenient response however with the
Bishop e6 meeting everything defending
against mate defending the rook and
striking at the Queen after now Queen c6
the bishop retreats but is still
throwing a punch of the Queen after
Queen d5 we have now c4 and this bishop
is officially out of squares and the
bishop is trapped
you